le cauchemar du brésil continue à
empirer plus de quinze mille décèdent
l'aco vide depuis le début du mois
d'avril qui va probablement dépasser le
record de 66000 du mois précédent les
hôpitaux sont saturés surtout dans la
grande région de san paolo
les enterrements doivent se faire de
nuit également et les cimetières sont
saturées au point de devoir vider des
tombes anciennes les médecins
spécialistes sonne l'alarmé
le brésil est l'épicentre de la pandémie
kovy dans le monde et les
épidémiologistes prévoit que le pays va
dépasser le demi million de morts d'ici
le 1er juillet s'approchant ainsi du
nombre total de décès aux etats-unis le
plus élevé de tous avec une population
plus important la police a récemment
effectué une descente dans un club de
san paulo bondée où les fêtards ne
prenait de toute évidence aucune
précaution ou comprend mieux son dos
ministère a fraudé ministère fait tout
son possible pour réduire la mortalité
dans les hôpitaux à sur le tout nouveau
ministre de la santé
mais la clé de la fin de la pandémie
c'est une rapide campagne de vaccination
vaccination qui est encore trop lente
faute de doses moins de 10% de la
population a reçu un premier vaccin
le brésil a trop hésité à choisir ses
vaccins et trop tarder dans ses
commandes
il faut dire que le président ball sonar
continue à souffler le chaud et le froid
sur le sujet est-ce que je vais me faire
vacciner
c'est la question j'ai déjà eu le virus
j'attendrai que le dernier brésiliens
soient vaccinés et après je déciderai de
me faire vacciner ou pas le président
s'est mise à dos plusieurs gouverneurs
dans celui de saint paulo
[Musique]
le président est un négationniste dit il
c'est lui qui est responsable de notre
manque de vaccins le brésil est en train
d'élaborer son propre vaccin
mais pour beaucoup il sera trop tard
jean michel leprince radio canada
montréal